my baby kitty la la baby cleanliness Oh
No
Salam alaikum wa rahmatu labor care to
boxing citizen dear friends welcome to
another episode of react to Quran with
me and brother Mohammed hijab
if you don't know me my name is Ali Dawa
anyways we're going to do today is we're
going to be doing reacting to Quran
react Quran but we'll be reacting to the
hold on so we are in a random place and
react to it
derive some benefit from it inshallah or
some reflections etc same as you guys
used to do the same as well so make sure
you guys get your Quran house as well
and react with us insha'Allah and then
we'll go to sleep in kefir and see if
there's anything extra that we can
derive from the verses so how many job
learn we'll go for it
so now Mahalo
we're gonna go home anyway well you have
to take one and a small one over 400k
always go with any take any let's go
here man let's go Hajj that's all what
it's happy it's a wise not in a lot of
additional look yeah okay you colors it
here go that one what's not which one
that number 206 children eight 208 okay
give me this is beautiful actually hold
on Rick yeah
oh you oh you believe or you believe
submit and Tyler to Allah and do not
walk in the devil's footstep assuredly
he is declared enemy to you if you slide
back after that the clear sides have
come to you then no Allah is what I
don't know this is a very interesting
word I haven't even come across in my
like Olga's wine August twice okay
made it all knowing why and then it says
that it considers go for these two
verses I think yes yeah you could go for
the third one as well okay
are they waiting for anything other than
Allah is coming to them in the shadow of
a cloud with all the angels and the
question is pass settled suit all ashore
things return okay would you saw
yeah okay so it says say yeah you only
didn't a medical efficient machinery
catheter well that's a telephoto to [ __ ]
on and basically says o you who believe
coming to Islam in its entirety and
don't follow the footsteps of the devil
now this interesting phraseology was
also mentioned to Abraham in the same
surah well I lost an analysis it's
called Eleanor Abu Aslam call Aslam
terrible enemy Allah said to Abraham
excellent meaning become Muslim
submissive and he said I've become
submissive to Allah lord of the worlds
it doesn't mean to say and this is so
interesting you know why
because if you think about it we already
Muslims this is quite a if you think
it's quite ironic because you say yeah
you're latina Amman oh yeah o you who
believe
also Hulu facilitate quadrotor Shaitaan
it says o you believe enter Islam
completely and don't follow the
footsteps of the devil which means
wherever you are in your spiritual
ladder yeah as a Muslim yeah then you
basically have a you can go up yet only
me yourself yeah you saying although who
knows is still me castrated meaning
completely because as Muslims we have
shortcomings we might find it difficult
to submit to some rules I would might
find it easy to submit several so what
Aslam is telling us what allah subhanaw
taala is telling us oh the whole
facility care for ten that come into
Islam in its entirety so don't think ok
I'm going to follow this part of Islam
and not this part of neck of another
Buffy and that's why and by the way in
the same surah yeah in surah al-baqarah
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala he mentions
after took me noona be Bob will he tell
you attack for gonna be bad he said you
believe in parts of the book and you
disbelieve in other parts of the book it
emerges a legend a fella came in the
kitchen said haigha to dunya that what
is the recompense of someone who does
that from you except that you have
basically humiliation in this world
William will clarity l didn't like Ida
like that yeah the end the day of
judgment they'll be returned to the most
to to a more painful punishment this is
by the way verse 200 and what do we say
let's say 200 and 800 yes yeah no Junaid
while you do that yes I'm gonna yeah so
move for one thing that is beneficial
for us and for me to react on it what I
said and do not walk in the devil's
footsteps shortly he is declared enemy -
yes sir so do not follow his footsteps
you know of what he did you know what
did he do you know he were built you
know imagine he was on the run of the
Angels yeah and because he envied and
was arrogant and jealous did his
characteristics here we're talking about
always his footsteps
listen carefully and he did not like
Adam Ali Saleh
yes and imagine do nothing almost ones
are clear to me and asking me to do
something any rejecting it and what are
you doing at that stage you are like
basically instead of acknowledge one
last thing and obeying you are taking
your arrogance your jealousy your envy
as a deity over Allah saying because
you're saying no I'm not because I'm
better than him you know so it's like I
was fans are saying do not take its
footsteps
arrogance you know envy jealousy you
know there is a hadith of the Pulsar
solemn and absorbed if I'm not mistaken
saying that jealousy burns goodies just
like fire destroys would you know so
don't follow his footsteps acknowledge
and also it says surely he is betrayed
you could be create any meat you know
your enemy this is your enemy so when
you know someone's a click enemy to you
you need to be careful you need to watch
his every step you need to be careful
because you need to see what's he going
to do to attack you because he is a
clear enemy to you he has sworn and off
by Allah might that Allah indeed Tobi
their judgment I am going to misguide
them he is given off because he is
doomed he's finished so he's saying I'm
going I'm going to take as much people
as I can with me yeah I'm gonna do the
maximum amount of damage you know so
that's why it's important to know your
enemy so why do we when it comes
biggest enemy when laid-back or calm we
don't care you know it doesn't mean
nothing
we don't do nothing to prepare ourselves
against him and his attacks from his
soldiers from the shayateen yeah so why
is it that we don't prepare knowing that
there's an outright declaration on war
against us we should be very firm Essene
you know what he's my enemy he's going
to try to take me down what can I do to
protect myself what is the biggest
weapon that we have the Book of Allah
yes and the sooner was Muhammad peace be
upon him to tell us how to deal with the
situation Geum jandi Allah has created
at least I was created you also when I
have a phone who knows that from best
the person who made it
they know that product best they know
what's good for and what's bad for it
Allah knows what's going to Basra and
Allah knows our enemy
so we have the Moho Allah and we have
the function of solemn Sunnah to help us
how like we said before in the episode
when the Shaitaan caller was what said
seek refuge in your Lord I would have
been lamina shaytan al rajim bismillah
my life
so you seeking refuge from Allah this is
a weapon what he's coming with a little
job you're like you know I'm saying yes
it's me oh you're protecting yourself so
we need to do that know your enemy look
he is declared enemy to you know your
enemy and this is really profound you
know what's interesting is the next
verses row because it says for envelopes
I'm inviting my Jets come and be in it
fellow more and the large isn't hacking
me so that if you are if you slip up
after the basically the guidance has
been shown or the clear signs have been
shown to you then know that Allah is
Aziz which means mighty I don't know how
to translate in the way translation
together and hacking which means were
white so his mighty and white so he
knows how to use is my and this is an
interesting construction why is it
interesting because if someone is very
mighty someone is very strong yes they
usually blur out that strength or they
abuse that friends like you'll see maybe
in different police again stuff like
that you'll find oppression because when
someone has the ability to do something
yes usually do it yes a lot of Herot
Alice has know a lot is Aziz and hacking
meaning he is as he is moving his mighty
and Hakim he knows how to use that might
in the right direction
but moreover he's warning us because
this is the justice of Allah sanitizer
for in Delta min bag images come with
bayonet if you slip up after the bayonet
have been shown to bayonet mitigated
clear proofs so allah subhanaw taala is
giving you an opportunity giving us an
opportunity to see the clear science be
exposed to the clear science and if you
yet deny the clear science then a lots
of paranoia is as is hacking meaning he
knows now how to exact punishment upon
the person who deserves that kind of
punishment because they've been exposed
and yet they are reluctant to engage
with the Islamic discourse yeah and so
so if you guys are always full of
baccala yeah verse 208 onwards
interesting reading so far and it says
in the next so I think you read up into
the next verse are they waiting for
anything other than a little area to
Malone if you do it basically it says
hey are they waiting for a lot of
parents Allah to come to them in the
clouds yeah and the angels what could
you along with the lives of jela more
basically that these pagan Arabs at the
time of the prophet mohammed salah
solidness i mean they were literally
asking and like the for example the
Benny sorry the children of Israel of
the time of Moses yeah they were asking
to see allah subhanaw taala and they
were asking that although they were
expecting something to be that profound
hmm but then the question doesn't
actually have a response a lot of Aunt
Alice it says are they looking for this
but he doesn't answer it then they're
going to get it or they're not going to
get it because it's an incredibly silly
request in the first place if if you
could see allah subhanho wa taala
won't be the point of the test if you
can see the angels coming down they'll
be absolutely no protest that would be
such a high level of evidence that there
would be no test
oh god I know you wonder you're gonna
believe and if you believe did what one
brought what they do I believe you know
this you you know there's obviously if
I'm not mistaken there's Hadees that
says those who did not see Allah and
believe in Allah there's a high like
great reward the Prophet
yeah the Prophet SAW Solomon said he
said that he was talking about how
strange it is that people in the future
who has never seen him but they will
believe him
the people who come up with every favor
time the Prophet Muhammad service and
I'm talking about liar but you're right
even the for example there's anything
about that as well yeah that that he
only said my brothers and he said also
about the hadith wasn't a blow like a
and the cat are alpha and lambda Kunta
alpha in no Iraq the hadith of gibreel
that you should live without seeing
Allah yeah you should worship allah
subhanaw taala which is headed for a
barrier I'm gonna pop up yeah it without
saying Allah me you should worship him
as if you see him because if he doesn't
you can't see him yeah he can still see
you yeah that is well but what I was
talking about is that basically the
reward is so high on the fact that you
didn't see Allah yeah and you worshipped
him you know
yeah that the world is so high because
that's all points you know the fact that
you believed in him you have signs not
have blind faith and also life you said
the person also said those who did not
seem like when he said like my brother
also are you talking about there he said
knows no those who did not see me but
believed in me here you know that's what
it's about because if you see the
prophets are assalam you know you know
and then our maybe our reward is greater
the fact that Sahaba was there they saw
it all happen in eternity that's a
different level of things but with us
the fact that clearly have our different
level to report is that was it a whole
new level but what what in this position
think that the function specifically
said ya know my brothers who are
believing me I didn't see me clear so
it's making like a distinction yes
absolutely there's a great reward it's
true you know how Allah so these verses
really they bring to prominence and to
light these themes which are very
important yeah first of all believing in
Allah without seeing him submitting to
him yes completely
believing in the hype generally yes not
asking for incredible kind of evidences
that would render the whole test yeah
void because it would be no point of the
test and finally to to to realize
attributes of Allah so Allah the fact
that is all-wise and Almighty from that
we can worship Allah knowing fully that
I have trusted him yes and he is in
general control over exactly so on
balance sisters know who you load it and
know who your enemy is very clearly and
is all of us from us today
hope you guys are benefited like I said
before we stop that verse 210 210 surah
Baqarah do carry on we didn't finish the
whole chapter in salah
and it's removable as well you know
you're not really enough in telling
reading inshallah thank you for tuning
in Allah bless you guys
it has control of grant every single
inning by Jenna till next time for me
and for my immediate family from where
I'm at right there
[Music]